how can you tell whether a relationship
is going to last the course
or whether it's doomed to founder what's
the difference between
fragile and solid couples here are
some of the things to look out for in
couples that seem
very fragile
fragile couples tend paradoxically to be
very
hopeful about love they associate
happiness
with conflict-free unions they don't
expect
once they've found the person they
unwisely see as the one
ever to need to squabble storm out of a
room
or feel unhappy for the afternoon when
trouble does emerge
as it inevitably will they don't greet
it as a sign that love is progressing as
it should
rather they take it as alarming evidence
that their relationship may be
illegitimate and fundamentally flawed
their hopes tire them for the patient
tasks of
diplomatic negotiation and routine
maintenance
fragile couples tend not to be good
detectives
of their own sufferings they may both be
rather unhappy
and yet unsure as to the actual causes
of their dissatisfactions
they know that something is wrong in
their unions but they can't easily trace
what they can't zero in on the way that
it was maybe
a lack of trust in them around money
that rankles with their partner
or that it's been their behavior towards
a demanding youngest child that's been
hurting
so they lash out in vague or inaccurate
directions
their attacks are either unfairly
general
or unconvincingly specific
someone who is shamed has fundamental
doubts about their right
to exist somewhere in the past they've
probably been imbued with an
impression that they don't matter very
much that their feelings should be
ignored
that their happiness is not a priority
that their words don't count
now once they're in a couple shamed
people
hurt like anyone else but their capacity
to turn their heart
into something another person can
understand and maybe be touched by
is very weak shamed people will start to
sulk
rather than explain they'll hide away
rather than share
they'll feel secretly wretched rather
than complaining honestly
it's frequently very late far too late
by the time shamed people finally let
their lovers know
more about the nature of what's driving
them to despair
complaining well requires an impression
that not everything depends on the
complaint being heard
perfectly right now were the points to
go a bit wrong
with a partner to prove a bit
intransigent one could survive
and maybe even take one's love elsewhere
not everything is at stake in every
argument
the partner hasn't ruined one's life one
therefore doesn't need to
scream hector insist or nag
one can deliver a complaint with some of
the casualness of a
calm teacher who wants an audience to
learn but can bear it if they don't
one could always say what was on one's
mind tomorrow
or the next day when everybody's had a
bit of rest
it takes an inner dignity not to mind
too much
about having to level complaints around
things that could sound laughably
small or that leave one open to being
described as
petty or needy with too much pride and
fear
it can become unbearable to admit that
one's been upset since lunchtime
because they didn't take one's hand on a
walk or that one wishes so much
that they would be readier to hug one
last thing at night
one has to feel pretty grown up inside
not to be offended
by one's own more childlike appetites
for reassurance and comfort it is an
achievement to know
how to be strong about one's
vulnerability
one may have said rather too many times
from behind a slammed door
in a defensive tone no no nothing is
wrong whatsoever
go away when secretly we're longing to
be comforted
and understood like a weepy upset child
fragile couples often come together with
few
positive childhood memories of
conversations that have worked out
early role models may simply have
screamed at each other
and then despaired these people may
never have witnessed disagreements
eventually evolving into mutual
understanding and sympathy
they would deeply love to be understood
but they can bring so few resources to
the task of making themselves so
none of these factors mean a couple will
have to split up
but they are generators of the states of
the kind of emotional disconnection
that can eventually break two people
apart outwardly
things may seemingly be well a couple
can have an interesting social life
maybe some lovely children a new
apartment
but a careful analysis will reveal a
high degree of risk
the good news is that knowing a little
about the risk factors
can help us to identify them in good
time and
with the help of some good advice for
example from the school of life
fix them while there is still time
please comment like and subscribe and
take a look at our shop for more from
the school of life